welcome to this video playing I'll go
koi Grandmaster I go koi and it is a
ceiling and yeah what about my pond
siani don't get the ponds what about
this may be a mmmm different a little
bit of a different line compared to the
Bishop b5 I mean this opening challenge
is about getting something different but
if possible I shouldn't play that the
same thing all the time this Bishop d3
is not so bad quite often leads to
positions that are yeah very real Lopez
type deform if I go d for you might play
CD CD night before grabbing my bishop so
I'm protecting e4 first I wonder if he
can go d5 here maybe d5 takes Queen
takes hmm that seems very ambitious
though unsure about that okay so and
let's get going cdcd night before this
should be three Bishop b5 that could be
one point ok now it's not it's not
relevant so he's doing something else
entirely um yeah two options I can play
d 50 i can trade only five keeping the
tension I don't know now maybe but ok I
will trade
it's a simple way to do it try to play
for this d5 weakness that's how the
fisher played it quite often trade like
to trade on e5 in the reuleaux pass and
give that's quite surprising that is
allowing that that he actually
encourages the straight I definitely
wanted to trade them increase my control
over 85 to be honest it looks like
pretty serious strategic mistake by oleg
oh my dears night d2c 43 and then 25 he
probably should go b5 which means maybe
a beehive b5 that that's probably quite
ok style
interesting that's also interesting but
the bishop on d5 is definitely a nice
piece on and it's not clear what is f
six bishop is doing
German be before is interesting i wonder
if i should do if i should go before at
some point cheeks i can take c3 really
okay maybe just quincy to keep it simple
yeah okay thanks like to trade that and
now off to d5 Bishop g5 might be a move
try to know seems he wants to reroute
that to c5 okay so I'm putting it there
f5 is an interesting way to go no Joe
okay is Bishop on c5 is not really a bad
bishop in the classic sense of the word
because it's an act of diagonal but
still right there on d5 that's that's
really neat what am I going to do though
Queenie to maybe Queenie 2nite age 49 f5
this kind of thing might be might be
good so thank you now f5 is difficult to
believe he's playing quite slowly here
so okay at 5i will take so I'm getting
going here because I think in general I
have to try to do something on the on
the Kings side look to the seven
hmm
Jim now it's not so it's not so bad now
I really i overestimated my position
here quite a bit that's not bad this
position for Black Knight f5 you can
check on d5 and we cannot have Quincy
form that's a important little thing now
do i do I have that my chief Queen g4g 6
yeah of course room 25 up 25 then it
sticks out okay so i can actually put in
the night there look t5 the squeegee for
so but he saw that ok so what about all
this Queen g4 or not
hmm Queen g4g six this is this f6 thing
f6 thing sometimes it should improve on
some some some expression there Knight
f6 check em eNOS is an idea um I was
thinking just this move Bishop e3
Queenie six every 696 check winsome
material but he might just move the king
then you really don't know what this
what this actually means Queen h4 takes
their Knight f6 check King g7 this
leading somewhere check their King g7
don't don't think don't they don't see I
don't see anything there
time warning maybe if I go back yeah
they're they're still threatening that
yeah I don't know it's not it's not that
great actually the whole thing
now now ice totally find them
oh that's a that's an annoying freely I
cannot allow the trade yeah this is oh
no Bishop d3 ah shoot i na i'm covering
that okay and i can take now wow I was
lucky black resigns it was lucky yeah i
think i think around here should be in
quite good shape but i miss played that
I really did maybe it's not not that
great God before something i don't
really i have to improve him the engine
wants to go before maybe this is
actually good like this not this like
this kind of thing and i have be formed
as a possible way of challenging this
Bishop them yeah so I went like this and
a 3 else is probably very lame a 3 is
some probably just a temple loss by the
way is not going to play before anyway
yeah that was a bit of a mindless move
here and a for now a four and then be
three yes that's actually good let's go
down if he takes Queen B 5 wins the pawn
and I'm attacking civil that's strong
yeah that's strong okay so that was the
real problem just six and now this is
not that great I was thinking first I
was thinking I could maybe go here Jim I
can just take your phone and here this
is not not good you're here I don't have
anything greater efrain check on g3 but
he just asked to fine minor pieces yeah
and here blackest black is calling the
shots
he's got the g file so had super
important mission for yeah oh yeah yeah
but I'm just busted him there was okay i
hear and loud a little bit here engine
wants to do this one key problem is said
at the end if he just gets rooks off
Bishop see one at the end picks up the
whole Queen side yeah the only way to
win really was that he blundered into
this here and the route was gone now
that was a lucky win okay well thanks
for watching